Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis Frédérique, je suis professeur de
lettres anglaises en lycée professionnel.
Ça fait dix ans que j’enseigne -
je sais, malgré tout, j’ai l’air jeune -
et ça fait sept ans que je suis
en poste ici-même à Amiens.
J’aime ma vie,
même si professeur, ce n’était pas
forcément la carrière dont j’avais rêvé.
J’ai suivi l’avis de mes parents :
« Tu verras, dans ce métier,
tu auras beaucoup de temps libre...
pour tes loisirs. »
Ils avaient raison dans un sens.
Parce que c’est vrai, comme tout le monde,
j’aime les loisirs et j’en avais pas mal.
Particulièrement, par exemple -
ce sont des exemples - le cinéma.
J’ai toujours aimé le cinéma américain,
l’âge d’or hollywoodien ; j’adorais ça.
Et par exemple aussi, la danse.
Je fais de la salsa, enfin, comme beaucoup
de femmes divorcées de province.
C’est fou.
Je suis quelqu’un de très investi
dans mon établissement.
Avec mes collègues et mes amis,
on fait tout pour faire bouger le lycée.
On organise la fête des talents,
les journées déguisées,
des voyages et même
le bal de promo de l’établissement.
À Amiens, c’est quelque chose,
je vous assure.
Très récemment, j'ai été inspectée.
C'était ma toute première inspection.
Ce n’est pas souvent
dans l’Éducation nationale.
J’avais un petit peu peur,
mais finalement super résultat
parce que ma séquence s’est retrouvée
mise en exemple sur le site du rectorat.
Pfou ! Pour une première inspection,
c’est quelque chose.
J'étais très fière.
Ça faisait extrêmement plaisir
de se voir reconnue
dans son travail, dans son métier.
Jusqu’à...
Hé oui, forcément, quelque chose
de difficile va se passer.
Jusqu’à ce matin de janvier 2014.
Je suis convoquée
dans le bureau de la directrice.
Je ne m’attends à rien. Et vous ?
Imaginez-vous :
nous sommes lundi matin, il est 8 heures.
« Madame, je vous ai convoquée
dans le bureau
parce que j’ai reçu une lettre anonyme,
à votre égard,
qui m’apprend que vous êtes stripteaseuse
sous le nom de Petula Goldfever,
et que vous réalisez vos strip-teases
durant vos arrêts de travail. »
Je vous l’ai dit, lundi matin, 8 heures.
Je m'attendais à beaucoup de choses,
mais franchement pas à ça.
Forcément, je suis restée
un peu bouche bée.
Rassurez-vous, ça continue.
« Des photos ont été jointes
à cette lettre.
J’ai tout vérifié sur Facebook :
tout est vrai.
J’ai donc tout envoyé au rectorat.
L’affaire est dorénavant entre
les mains de Monsieur le recteur. »
Waouh !
Bon, on n’est plus vraiment dans une
histoire, même dans un fait divers banal.
Là, c’est franchement saison deux,
Netflix, c’est la totale.
Moi je suis totalement abasourdie.
Donc maintenant,
il est lundi matin, 8 h 02.
Ma vie a basculé.
Et là, je me dis : « Mais attendez,
quelle histoire rocambolesque !
Mais vous me parlez d’une lettre anonyme,
vous me parlez de photos, vous...
Mais allez-y, montrez-moi.
Montrez-moi cette lettre
au lieu de m’en lire des extraits.
Montrez-moi les photos. De quoi ça parle ?
Moi, je veux voir, je veux savoir.
En plus, lettre anonyme,
moi qui adore le cinéma,
était-ce des lettres découpées dans
des journaux, comment ça avait été collé ?
Le cachet de la Poste, est-ce qu’il y a
un lieu, une date sur l’enveloppe ?
Enfin voilà, vous comprenez
quand même ces questions. »
Vous savez ce qu’elle m’a répondu,
la directrice ?
« Non, je ne le montrerai
qu’à la police. »
(Siffle)
Alors là, Colombo, Sherlock Holmes,
ils étaient tous avec moi,
on n'en pouvait plus.
« Comment ça ?
On se moque de moi.
Ça fait sept ans que je travaille
dans cet établissement,
que je suis investie dans le travail.
On reçoit une lettre à mon sujet,
on refuse de me la montrer,
on m’infantilise
parce qu’on m’en lit des extraits,
on se fait juge comme en cour d’Assises,
et on ne me laisse même pas
un droit de réponse, un droit de parole.
Et la police ?
Non mais attendez, vous rigolez ?
Mais elle contient quoi cette lettre
pour que vous me parliez de la police ?
Alors soit.
J'ai joué le jeu, je suis joueuse.
Et puis facile, le commissariat,
il suffisait de traverser la rue.
Alors je l’ai fait, j’ai traversé la rue.
Le sourire de la brigadière quand
j’ai expliqué l’énoncé de la plainte.
On ne savait pas trop où la placer.
Le plus drôle,
c’est qu’elle avait une question.
C’est assez cocasse, mais elle s’est
demandé, de fonctionnaire à fonctionnaire,
si finalement je ne gagnerais pas
plus d’argent en étant strip-teaseuse
plutôt que professeur
de l’Éducation nationale ?
Ça nous a laissées un peu rêveuses.
Et vous, je pense que vous vous posez
certainement une autre question.
Vous devez certainement vous demander :
« Mais alors,
c’est vrai ou ce n’est pas vrai ?
Allez, allez, dis-nous tout. »
Moi, de mon point de vue,
j’avais une autre question
qui m’ennuyait profondément :
« Mais qui a écrit une lettre
anonyme à mon sujet ? »
C'est quand même dingue.
Vous imaginez : d’un seul coup,
on se réveille un matin
et on a un ennemi ou une ennemie,
un corbeau, une corneille,
quelqu’un qui fait tout, pernicieux
comme ça, pour vous vouloir du mal.
Là, je vous assure,
on soupçonne tout le monde.
Ses copains, ses copines, ses amies,
ses petits amis, ses ex-maris,
ses collègues, ses voisins,
ses parents, la totale.
Et parmi toutes ces suspicions,
je me suis rendu compte d’une évidence :
je ne voulais pas que cette personne
soit satisfaite du résultat.
Je ne voulais pas laisser
à ce corbeau ou cette corneille
la satisfaction, le sentiment
d’avoir gagné.
Alors donc -
j’ai beaucoup avancé, excusez-moi.
Je me suis dit, pour cela,
qu’il faudrait que plus jamais on ne
puisse dénoncer quelque chose à mon sujet.
Pour cela,
plus jamais il faudrait
que j’ai quelque chose à cacher.
Car oui, c'est vrai.
Allez, je vous l’avoue,
j’avais un petit secret.
J’avais découvert le cabaret burlesque
à l’occasion de la sortie du film
« Tournée » de Mathieu Amalric, en 2011,
Il avait gagné le Prix
de la mise en scène à Cannes.
Je suis fan de cinéma.
Forcément, j’ai été au courant,
forcément, je suis allée le voir,
forcément, ça m’a inspirée.
J’ai eu envie de m’y mettre, à
l’effeuillage burlesque, envie d’essayer.
Un peu comme la pole dance pour un EVJF.
Quand on veut essayer,
on veut tenter l’affaire.
J’ai regardé sur Internet, sur Google :
« Burlesque Picardie ».
Rien, que dalle, nada.
Le burlesque n’existait pas en Picardie,
mais ce n’était pas grave.
J’ai pris ma voiture, ma petite
Peugeot 205, et je suis descendue à Paris.
Et j’ai pris des cours.
Tous les week-ends, j’y allais,
j’étais assidue et j’apprenais.
C’était chouette, c’était sympa.
Et puis un jour,
un copain qui présentait des cabarets
burlesques, mais en Belgique, m’a dit :
« Allez Fred, je te sens prête.
Viens avec moi, tu seras mon assistante. »
Eh bien, vous savez quoi ?
Notre duo a fait un carton.
Moi, je m’étais créé un personnage
totalement fantasque
qui faisait tout pour qu’on la remarque.
Je faisais des blagues, des mimiques,
tout en installant les décors sur la scène
et en ramassant les effets
des effeuilleuses.
Ce n’est absolument pas à ce moment-là
pour la photo, mais merci. (Rires)
Je vous en prie, je vous le dirai
quand il y aura la « cue ».
Vous n’avez rien vu,
vous clignez des yeux, très bien.
Donc je ramassais
tous les petits effets par terre.
On se produisait en Belgique, en Suisse,
mais on n’avait encore
jamais travaillé en France.
On n’était pas connus ici.
Mais voilà, on avançait petit à petit,
moi, assistante du présentateur.
Donc, oui, je vous l’avoue, c’est vrai,
je faisais du cabaret le week-end.
Et alors ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on pouvait
me reprocher, au final ?
Je me suis souvenue
de ce qu’on m’avait lu,
éventuellement la mention
« pendant ses arrêts de travail ».
Je me suis dit qu’éventuellement,
il y avait un petit hic
parce que c’est vrai, on sera d’accord,
c’est quand même difficile d’aller prouver
qu’à telle date,
j’étais vraiment malade dans mon lit,
pas en train de boire le thé
avec une copine.
Non, non, non, je ne suis pas partie
une journée en avance en vacances
alors qu’on connaît tous et toutes
une Véro de la compta qui un jour a abusé.
Et pire, imaginez si jamais
vous aviez un deuxième job
alors que vous êtes indemnisé
par la Sécurité sociale.
Là, je peux comprendre, ça peut chauffer.
Et qu’est-ce que je peux
prouver ou y faire ?
Mais en fait, vous savez quoi ?
Pas du tout.
Le rectorat, la mention
« pendant ses arrêts de travail »,
ça ne les a pas intéressés longtemps.
Vous savez ce qui les a intéressés ?
C’est la mention « striptease ».
Ah ça oui, ça oui,
ça, ça les a bien intéressés.
Mais moi je n’ai pas compris.
Je n’ai pas compris pourquoi faire
du cabaret en amateur le week-end,
ça allait être plus choquant
que des cours de danse
en justaucorps hyper-moulant
tous les mardis soir
pour faire son spectacle
de fin d’année à la MACU.
Je suis désolée, moi,
je ne voyais pas la différence.
Et c’est là que j’ai compris quelque chose
que je ne soupçonnais pas.
Vous savez, dans mon métier,
J’ai toujours su que l’État, le rectorat,
avaient un droit de regard sur ma parole
en tant qu’enseignante -
ma parole en classe.
Jamais je n’aurais pensé qu’ils
auraient un droit de regard
sur ce que je faisais
de mon corps le week-end.
Et pourtant.
J’étais totalement anéantie
par cette idée de lettre anonyme.
Je n’en dormais plus, j’étais
en dépression, j’ai perdu du poids.
Mais ça, c’est un autre TEDx.
(Rires)
L’idée
que Monsieur le Recteur pouvait
avoir un droit de regard
sur mes activités le week-end,
ça, ça me révoltait.
Ils ont invoqué la dignité
due à ma fonction.
Dignité !
Je ne sais pas vous, surtout les filles,
mais moi dignité, depuis que je suis ado,
je sais que ma dignité dépend
de la longueur de ma jupe.
Je ne suis pas dupe.
Jusqu'à mes 30 ans, ma dignité dépendait
de l'intensité de mon rouge à lèvres.
Si c'était trop rose, ça faisait gamine.
Si c’était trop rouge,
attention, ça faisait pute.
Mais,
si je n’étais pas assez maquillée,
ah la la la la, j’avais l’air malade.
Et si je pouvais faire du sport pour
perdre des cuissots, ce serait pas mal.
Mais attention, parce qu’une femme
trop musclée, ce n’est pas élégant.
« Tu pourrais quand même dire merci quand
on te dit un compliment dans la rue.
Même si on se connaît pas.
Puis t’as qu’à pas rouler du cul,
comme ça, au moins on ne dira rien.
Et puis de toute façon,
comment veux-tu qu’on te respecte
puisque tu oses sortir seule le soir ? »
Ah ouais ! Et voilà !
On y était, encore une fois.
Encore une fois, il faudrait se justifier.
Encore une fois, il va falloir s’excuser.
Encore une fois, il va falloir
se démaquiller, se couvrir,
se cacher et arrêter de se démarquer.
Ben non, j’avais 32 ans.
Franchement, j’en avais marre,
ce n’était plus possible.
Et puis, excusez-moi,
quelles lois enfreint-on
lorsqu’on danse sur scène
en bas résille et en cache-tétons ?
(Rires)
J’ai cherché, je n’ai pas trouvé.
Quelles lois enfreint-on
lorsqu’on se déshabille ?
Un acte aussi banal que vous tous là,
vous réalisez absolument chaque soir,
tous les jours, j’espère,
durant toute votre vie.
Alors je suis partie dans des digressions
parce que j’essayais de comprendre les
limites et les choses qu’on me reprochait.
Alors imaginons, faisons des parenthèses.
Et si on m’avait accusée de nudisme ?
Est-ce que le nudisme est autorisé
par l’Éducation nationale ?
Je ne sais pas vous, mais le nudisme :
tout le monde est tout nu et
les enfants sont à hauteur de sexe.
Donc je ne sais pas si c’est mieux.
(Rires)
Et si j’avais été modèle vivant
à l’Académie des Beaux-Arts,
est-ce que ça serait passé ?
La nudité pour l’Académie, ça passe ?
Je ne sais pas.
Et si j’avais été championne
du monde de pole dance ?
Est-ce qu’on aurait loué
mes capacités sportives
ou est-ce qu’on m’aurait
reproché le petit bikini
qui est indispensable
à la pratique du sport ?
Oui, il faut que la peau soit nue,
sinon sur la pole, ça ne tient pas,
tu glisses, tu tombes.
Mauvais, vraiment.
Et là, je vous entends :
« Oui, mais ça n’a rien à voir.
Frédérique, tu pars dans
des digressions pas possibles.
L'effeuillage, c'est totalement différent.
L’effeuillage, ça veut dire sensualité,
et la sensualité,
ça évoque la sexualité, etc. etc. »
Ok, d’accord. Alors, imaginons de nouveau.
Et si jamais j’avais pratiqué
l’échangisme le week-end ?
Vous pensez que l’Education nationale
interdit l’échangisme ?
Alors pareil, j’ai cherché, mais il n’y
avait rien dans le contrat de travail.
Là, vous allez me dire : « Oh ça va,
ça va, tu vas trop loin, tu vas trop loin.
L’effeuillage, la vraie différence,
c’est que ça se fait devant un public. »
Oui, enfin, l’échangisme aussi
des fois, mais bon.
(Rires)
Il n’empêche qu’il m’est toujours
resté en tête une véritable question.
Et si j’avais été un homme,
est-ce qu’on ne m’aurait pas simplement
tapé sur l’épaule en disant :
« Ah, c’est bon, Marcel, bravo !
Quelle virilité, quelle audace !
Bravo ! Ça, c’est du mec ! »
Moi, je ne suis qu'une femme.
Je fais du cabaret burlesque et c'est mal.
Et pourtant je ne fais pas de numéro.
Mais non, je vous l’ai dit, je ne suis
que l’assistante du présentateur
et je vous laisse juger de mon indignité
dans cette image
que vous découvrez à l’instant.
(Rires)
Et...
puisque le rectorat - et ma directrice -
croyaient dur comme fer
à mes capacités de stripteaseuse,
allez !
Je suis bonne élève, je n’allais
quand même pas les décevoir, non ?
J’ai pris mon courage à deux mains,
je me suis lancée
et j’ai créé mon tout premier
numéro d’effeuillage burlesque.
Et puis toute fébrile, en m’étant
entraînée comme ça dans mon salon,
je me suis inscrite à un concours,
en Belgique toujours.
Et devinez quoi ?
J’ai remporté le premier prix !
Alors là, merci, merci.
(Applaudissements)
Et là, vous ne pouvez pas
savoir le soulagement.
Là, d’un seul coup,
je n’avais plus rien à cacher.
J’assumais tout et je me
sentais digne, la tête haute.
Plus rien ne pouvait m’arrêter ;
je me suis dit : « Allez ! on continue. »
Et la deuxième fois sur scène,
avec ce même numéro,
hop, j’étais déjà
dans un show professionnel
qui se jouait à guichets fermés,
auquel j’ai pu participer.
Je n’ai pas été payée, j’ai forcé la
productrice, fait des pieds et des mains.
Mais ça se jouait à Paris -
ma première date française -
à Paris, au Théâtre de la Reine
Blanche, dans le 18e.
Imaginez l'émotion, la sensation.
Là, on est vraiment dans
quelque chose d’hyper important.
Je suis en coulisses, je suis sur le côté.
La musique démarre, la scène s'allume,
j'avance.
Et là...
Je les vois : Hélène, Claire, Anne-So,
mes collègues, mes collègues profs,
mes copines.
Elles sont là,
elles ont fait le déplacement.
Elles se sont mises là, devant,
au tout premier rang, juste au milieu.
Pas pour être sûres de me voir.
Franchement, on voit
beaucoup mieux de plus loin.
Mais parce qu’elles voulaient me montrer
qu’elles étaient là pour moi, avec moi.
Et ça, c'était beau.
Et là, vous savez,
je me suis rendu compte que...
ben...
je n’étais pas seule.
Je n’étais pas seule dans mon combat.
Je n’avais pas forcément
encore tous les mots,
mais j’avais déjà la sensation
qu’en m’engageant dans le burlesque,
j’allais défendre la liberté des femmes
à disposer de leur corps.
Je le savais car non,
je ne suis pas indigne
quand je monte sur scène.
Les seuls qui étaient indignes
dans cette histoire,
c’était mes responsables
qui se sont évertués
à traiter avec mépris et hypocrisie
mon engagement artistique et politique.
Même si à l’époque,
je n’avais pas encore tous les mots
pour pouvoir définir ce qui se passait.
Je vais vous le dire aujourd’hui -
car aujourd’hui, je les ai les mots.
Quand une femme monte sur scène,
Quand elle reprend comme moi,
ici devant vous,
les codes de séduction et les critères
de beauté totalement inatteignables
avec lesquels on nous bassine
depuis des dizaines d’années,
dans le cinéma, à la télé, dans la presse.
Ces codes inatteignables
qui nous torturent,
nous les femmes, depuis notre enfance.
Eh bien la femme qui monte sur scène,
elle se les approprie, ces clichés.
Elle les surexpose, elle les modèle,
elle les détourne.
Et puis, elle s’en moque.
Elle finit par ne plus baisser les yeux
face aux regards des autres
et elle se libère
de toutes les injonctions.
Et vous voyez,
finalement, moi aussi, je me suis libérée.
J’ai démissionné
de l’Éducation nationale en 2014
suite à ce dernier courrier
de Monsieur le Recteur.
Je m’excuse pour les presbytes,
mais c’est comme ça.
En essence, Monsieur le Recteur m’autorise
à pratiquer le burlesque
sur mon temps libre -
Je vois quelqu’un qui prend la [lettre]
en photo, mais je pourrais vous l’envoyer.
J’ai les droits de ce document
qui m’est adressé.
Monsieur le Recteur, donc,
m’autorise à faire du burlesque,
sous réserve bien sûr de la dignité
qui incombe à ma fonction.
Youpi !
Mais attention,
Monsieur le recteur m’interdit
de faire du burlesque sur le territoire
académique, c’est-à-dire la Picardie.
(Siffle)
Je vous l’ai dit,
ça n’existait pas en Picardie.
Donc déjà...
Et puis franchement, entre nous,
pour un gars qui a quand même basé tout
son argumentaire sur une lettre anonyme
et des photos volées sur Facebook,
il ne manque pas de toupet.
Franchement,
c’était l’interdiction de trop.
Je suis donc partie.
Et finalement grâce
à mon corbeau ou ma corneille,
je suis dorénavant Petula Goldfever.
Je suis effeuilleuse professionnelle.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Il va falloir s’arrêter un moment.
Je vous remercie.
J'ai douze minutes seulement pour parler,
donc il va falloir les arrêter un moment.
Depuis ma démission en 2014,
j’ai fait tourner mes pompons -
avec dignité, bien sûr,
comme cela incombe à ma fonction -
dans plus de 400 manifestations
ou événements,
et ce, dans plus d’une quinzaine de pays.
Et puisqu’on m’avait interdit de faire
du burlesque en Picardie,
j’ai décidé d’y créer la toute première
école d’effeuillage de la région en 2016 :
Amiens burlesque.
J’espère que Monsieur le Recteur est là.
(Rires)
Ce serait bien.
(Applaudissements)
Vous savez, en à peine trois ans
d’existence d’Amiens burlesque,
j’avais donné confiance en elles
à près d’une centaine de femmes qui
tournaient leurs pompons avec moi.
Je leur ai appris à arrêter de s’excuser.
À arrêter de s’excuser que -
je sais pas moi,
mais disons, par exemple, leur popotin.
Ah.
(Rires)
Excusez-moi. Problème technique.
Voilà. C’est réglé.
Je vous l’ai dit, professionnel.
(Rires)
Elles ont arrêté de s’excuser
que leur popotin était trop gros,
oh ! l’arrière-train, trop flasque.
Terrible, les fesses qui tombent
à partir de 40 ans.
Pire, le fessier qui déborde
éhontément de la culotte.
Terrible.
Je vous remercie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Ça se tient bien.
Je crois qu’ils m’ont mise à ce moment-là
pour vous réveiller un petit peu
en deuxième partie, (Rires)
pour être sûr.
Moi, à ces femmes,
je leur ai appris à maîtriser les
attitudes, les codes, de la femme fatale,
je leur ai appris à arrêter de se cacher
derrière des vêtements trop amples
et trop sombres,
et je leur ai appris
qu’elles pouvaient être, elles aussi,
aussi charismatiques que
les femmes des magazines.
Et aujourd’hui, voyez-vous,
je suis Petula Goldfever
et je continuerai à enseigner
des techniques de danse et de théâtre
pour aider toutes les femmes à s'assumer.
Et les hommes aussi, s’ils veulent -
je n’ai pas de problèmes.
Je continuerai à inspirer aux femmes
le courage de se lever et de se montrer.
J’aimerais également
que mon histoire soit un exemple
pour toutes ces femmes qui ont peur,
qui n’osent pas, j’allais dire, affronter
les personnes ou les institutions
qui les méprisent ou les rabaissent.
Je voudrais
que toutes ces femmes comprennent
que leur plus grande force,
c’est leur confiance en elles.
J’espère transmettre cela durant
mes cours d’effeuillages, bien sûr,
mais également via les numéros
que je réalise sur scène.
Car avec mes numéros,
je détourne les clichés
et forcément le male gaze,
le regard masculin.
Là, ce n’est pas forcément évident,
mais je vous assure, c’est ce que je fais.
(Rires)
Je m’appelle Petula Goldfever.
J'étais à Las Vegas la semaine passée.
Ce soir, je suis à Amiens, avec vous.
Et dès demain, je continuerai
à conquérir le monde
dépoussiérer les esprits étriqués.
(Applaudissements)